Como se ha dicho, cada vez que venimos aquí, aprendemos algo.
Esta mañana, los expertos mundiales
de tres o cuatro empresas dedicadas a la fabricación de sillas,
aparentemente han concluído que la solución es que la gente no se siente.
Eso podría habérselo dicho yo.
Risas
Ayer, los fabricantes de automóviles nos mostraron nuevos descubrimientos.
Indicaron que, creo que dijeron en unos 30 a 50 años,
estarán manejando coches con controles electrónicos,
sin toda la parte mecánica.
(Risas)
Resulta tranquilizador.
(Aplausos)
Entonces, comentaron que existiría algo así como otros controles eléctricos
para deshacerse de toda la parte mecánica.
Y eso está muy bien pero, ¿por qué no deshacerse de todos los cables?
Así no necesitas nada para controlar el coche, salvo pensar en ello.
Me encantaría hablar sobre tecnología
y en algún momento, cuando pasen mis 15 minutos,
me gustaría hablar con todos los "geeks" que haya
de lo que hay aquí.
Pero si hay algo que decir sobre esto, antes de meternos en tema,
sería que desde el momento que empezamos a construir esto,
la idea principal no era la tecnología.
Se convirtió en una gran idea tecnológica cuando empezamos a aplicarlo
en el iBOT para la comunidad de discapacitados.
La gran idea aquí es, creo, una pieza nueva en la solución
a un problema bastante serio de transporte.
Y quizá para ponerlo en perspectiva... esto contiene tantos datos
que me gustaría dároslos de distintas formas.
Nunca sabes lo que le llama la atención a cada persona,
pero todo el mundo acepta sin problemas que el coche cambió el mundo.
Y Henry Ford, hace unos 100 años, empezó a arrancar a manivela el Modelo T.
En lo que no creo que piense la mayoría
es en el contexto en que se aplica la tecnología.
Por ejemplo, en ese momento, el 91% de los estadounidenses
vivía en granjas o pueblos pequeños.
De modo que el automóvil...
el carro sin caballos que sustituyó al coche de caballos, fue todo un cambio;
iba el doble de rápido que el coche de caballos;
ocupaba la mitad del largo;
y era una mejora medioambiental, porque por ejemplo,
en 1903 prohibieron los coches de caballos en el centro de Manhattan,
porque ya os podéis imaginar el aspecto que tenían las calles
cuando un millón de caballos
andan por ahí orinando y haciendo otras cosas...
y los problemas de salud y de otras índoles que creaban es casi inimaginable.
Así que el coche fue la alternativa medioambiental limpia al carro de caballos.
También fue la forma de que la gente fuera de granja a granja,
o de la granja al pueblo, o del pueblo a la ciudad.
Todo tenía sentido, ya que el 91% de la gente vivía allí.
Para los años 50 empezamos a conectar todos los pueblos
con lo que mucha gente proclamó la Octava Maravilla del mundo, el sistema de carreteras.
Ciertamente es una maravilla.
Y por cierto, ahora que hablamos de tecnologías antiguas,
quiero garantizarle a todo el mundo, y en particular a la industria automovilística
que nos ha apoyado mucho,
que no creo que esto compita de ninguna manera con los aviones o los coches,
pero pensad en el lugar en el que está el mundo ahora.
El 50% de la población mundial ahora vive en ciudades.
Eso son 3.200 millones de personas.
Hemos resuelto todos los problemas de transporte
que han cambiado el mundo para llegar a donde estamos ahora.
Hace 500 años, los barcos empezaron a lograr una relativa fiabilidad
y encontramos un continente nuevo.
Hace 150 años, las locomotoras lograron la suficiente eficiencia, el vapor,
como para que convirtiéramos el continente en un país.
En el último siglo hemos empezado a construir coches;
en los últimos 50 años, hemos conectado todas las ciudades entre sí
de una forma increíblemente eficaz,
y ahora tenemos un nivel de vida muy alto como consecuencia de ello.
Pero durante todo ese proceso, han nacido cada vez más personas,
y cada vez más gente se ha mudado a las ciudades.
Sólo en China se mudarán de 400 a 600 millones de personas
a las ciudades en la próxima década y media.
Y nadie, creo, discutiría que los aviones, en los últimos 50 años,
han convertido el continente y el país en un barrio más.
Y si observáis cómo se ha aplicado la tecnología,
veréis que hemos resuelto todos los problemas de cómo mover grandes pesos y
grandes volúmenes a gran velocidad y en grandes distancias.
Nadie quisiera dejar eso de lado.
Y sin duda, yo no quisiera dejar de usar mi avión,
o mi helicóptero, o mi todoterreno, o mi Porsche.
Me gustan todos. No los tengo encerrados en mi sala.
El hecho es que el último kilómetro es el problema,
y la mitad del mundo ahora vive en ciudades densamente pobladas.
La gente gasta, dependiendo de quiénes sean,
entre el 90 y el 95% de su energía yendo a los sitios a pie.
Creo que... no sé qué datos os impresionarían,
pero alrededor de un 43% del petróleo refinado que se produce en el mundo
lo consumen los coches de las zonas metropolitanas de los Estados Unidos.
3 millones de personas mueren por año en las ciudades por culpa de la contaminación del aire,
y casi toda la contaminación que existe en el planeta
la producen los medios de transporte, especialmente en las ciudades.
Y repito que no lo digo para atacar a ninguna industria.
Creo... de verdad que sí, que adoro los aviones,
y los coches que circulan por la carretera a 95 km/h
son increíblemente eficientes,
tanto desde un punto de vista de ingeniería,
como desde un punto de vista de consumo energético y de practicidad.
A todos nos gustan nuestros coches, a mí también.
El problema surge cuando estás en una ciudad, quieres ir a cuatro calles
y deja de ser divertido, eficiente o productivo.
No es sostenible.
En China, en el año 1998, 417 millones de personas usaban bicicleta,
y 1,7 millones de personas usaban coche.
Si el cinco por ciento de esa población llegara a ser "clase media",
y quisiera hacer las cosas como las hemos hecho nosotros en el último siglo...
al mismo tiempo que el 50% de la población se está mudando a ciudades
del tamaño y la densidad de Manhattan cada seis semanas...
no es ecológicamente sostenible,
no es económicamente sostenible... no hay suficiente petróleo.
Y no es políticamente sostenible.
Es decir, ¿por qué nos estamos peleando ahora?
Podemos tergiversarlo pero, ¿por qué se está peleando el mundo ahora mismo?
Así que me pareció que alguien tenía que trabajar en ese último kilómetro,
y fue pura suerte que nosotros estuviéramos trabajando en los iBOT.
Pero en cuanto hicimos esto, decidimos al instante
que podría ser una alternativa estupenda a las motos de agua. No necesitas agua.
O a las motos de nieve. No necesitas nieve.
O al esquí. Es divertido y a la gente le encanta andar por ahí haciendo cosas divertidas.
Y cada una de esas industrias, por cierto...
sólo los carros de golf generan beneficios multimillonarios.
Pero en vez de ponerle una licencia, que es lo que haríamos normalmente,
me pareció que si concentrábamos todos nuestros esfuerzos no en la tecnología,
sino en comprender un mundo que ya ha resuelto todos los demás problemas,
pero que ha aceptado de alguna forma que las ciudades, que
desde la Antigua Grecia fueron ideadas para caminar por ellas,
ciudades que fueron ideadas y construidas para la gente,
ahora tienen un tamaño que,
aunque hemos resuelto todos los demás problemas de transporte,
es como la ley de Moore.
Es decir, mirad el tiempo que se tardaba en cruzar un continente en un vagón Conestoga,
luego en tren, luego en avión.
Todas las demás formas de transporte han ido mejorando.
En 5.000 años hemos ido hacia atrás en la manera de recorrer las ciudades.
Cada vez son más grandes, están más extendidas.
La propiedad más cara del planeta en cada ciudad,
Wilshire Boulevard, o la Quinta Avenida, o Tokio, o París;
las propiedades más caras están en el centro.
El 65% del terreno de nuestras ciudades lo ocupan coches aparcados.
Las 20 ciudades más grandes del mundo.
Así que te preguntas, ¿y si las ciudades pudieran dar a sus peatones
lo que damos por sentado cuando vamos de una ciudad a otra?
¿Y si pudiéramos hacerlas divertidas, atractivas, limpias,
y ecológicas?
¿Y si tener acceso con esto, como último enlace con el transporte público,
fuera un poco más aceptable,
para poder dejar el coche y que todos pudiéramos vivir en la periferia
y usáramos los coches como quisiéramos,
y así nuestras ciudades se revitalizaran?
Creimos que estaría muy bien poder hacer eso,
y uno de los problemas que nos preocupaban era,
¿cómo hacemos que sea legal usarlo por la acera?
Porque técnicamente tiene motor, tiene ruedas... es un vehículo a motor.
No parezco un vehículo a motor.
Tengo el mismo tamaño que un peatón,
tengo la misma capacidad única
para lidiar con otros peatones en un lugar abarrotado.
Me llevé esto a la Zona Cero,
y me pasé una hora sorteando a la gente.
Soy un peatón. Pero la ley suele relegar la tecnología una o dos generaciones,
y si nos dicen que no podemos estar en la acera, tenemos dos opciones.
Somos un vehículo de recreo que no tiene relevancia,
y no gasto mi tiempo haciendo ese tipo de cosas.
O quizá debiéramos estar en la calle,
delante de un autobús o de un coche.
Hemos estado tan preocupados por eso
que acudimos al Director de la Oficina de Correos de Estados Unidos
como la primera persona fuera de la empresa a la que se lo enseñamos
y le dijimos, "Haz que tu gente lo use, todo el mundo se fía de los carteros.
Ellos van por la acera, y lo usarán formalmente".
Accedió. Acudimos a una serie de departamentos de policía
que querían que sus agentes volvieran a los barrios,
a patrullar, cargando con 30 kilos de cosas. Les encantó.
Y no creo que un policía se ponga una multa a sí mismo.
(Risas)
Así que hemos trabajado mucho, mucho,
aunque sabíamos que la tecnología no sería tan difícil de desarrollar
como una actitud sobre qué es importante, y cómo aplicar la tecnología.
Salimos a la calle y encontramos a algunos visionarios
con bastante dinero para permitirnos construir estas cosas,
y, con suerte, con el tiempo suficiente para que las aceptaran.
Así que estoy contento, de verdad, me alegro de hablar de esto tanto como queráis.
Y sí, es muy divertido, y sí, deberíais salir a la calle y probarlo.
Pero si pudiera pediros que hiciérais una cosa,
no sería pensar en esto como un objeto tecnológico,
sino imaginar que, aunque todos comprendemos de alguna forma
que es razonable que usemos máquinas de 1.800 kilos
que pueden ir a 95 kilómetros por hora,
y que pueden llevarte a donde quieras ir,
de alguna forma también es lo que usamos el último kilómetro,
y no va más, no funciona.
Una de las cosas más emocionantes que se nos ocurrió
sobre porqué podría ser aceptado, ocurrió aquí en California.
Hace unas semanas, después de lanzarlo,
estábamos aquí con un equipo de televisión en Venice Beach, yendo de aquí para allá,
y estaban todos maravillados con la tecnología
mientras las bicicletas nos pasaban por al lado,
y los monopatines,
y una ancianita... o sea, si buscaras en el diccionario...
una ancianita, se me acercó;
yo estaba subido a esto, soy un adulto de estatura normal,
y ella se detuvo, la cámara estaba ahí, y miró hacia arriba
y me dijo, "¿Puedo probarlo?"
¿Y yo qué iba...? Bueno, ¿cómo le iba a decir que no?
Así que le dije, "Claro".
Así que me bajé, ella se subió, y con un poquito de susto inicial normal,
se dio la vuelta, recorrió unos seis metros,
se dio la vuelta hacia nosotros y sonrió.
Volvió a donde estaba yo, se detuvo y me dijo,
"Por fin han hecho algo para nosotros".
La cámara le estaba apuntando.
Y yo pensaba, "¡Jo! Qué bien..."
(Risas)
"... por favor, señora, no diga nada más".
La cámara le estaba apuntando,
y este chico tuvo que ponerle el micrófono en la cara
le dice, "¿A qué se refiere con eso?"
Y pensé, "Aquí se acaba todo".
Y ella miró hacia arriba y dijo, "Bueno,"
todavía estaba viendo a los demás y dice, "no sé montar en bici". No,
dijo, "no sé montar en monopatín, y nunca me he puesto unos patines".
Conocía los nombres...
Y dijo, "Y han pasado 50 años desde la última vez que monté en bici".
Entonces miró hacia arriba, nos estaba mirando y dijo,
"Tengo 81 años, ya no puedo conducir un coche,
todavía tengo que ir de compras, y no puedo cargar con mucho peso".
Y entonces me dí cuenta de que, entre mis muchos miedos,
no era sólo que la burocracia, la normativa
y los legisladores no lo aceptaran,
sino, esencialmente, crees que habrá presión entre la gente
para que no se invada el poco espacio libre que queda:
las aceras de las ciudades.
Cuando ves que por ley tiene que haber 90 centímetros de acera,
luego 2 metros y medio de aparcamiento, luego tres carriles,
luego los otros dos metros y medio... es...
ese pedacito es lo único que queda.
Pero ella mira hacia arriba y dice esto,
y entonces se me ocurre que, bueno, a los chicos no les van a importar esas cosas,
y ellos no votan, y a los hombres de negocios y a los adultos jóvenes
tampoco les van a importar esas cosas, ellos son bastante "cool",
así que creo que inconscientemente estaba preocupado
por que la población más mayor fuera a preocuparse por eso.
Así que, después de haber visto eso y de haberme preocupado durante 8 años,
lo primero que hago es levantar el teléfono y decirle a nuestra gente de márketing
y legislación que llamen a la Asociación de Personas Mayores y concierten una
cita. Tenemos que enseñarles esto.
Se lo llevaron a Washington, se lo enseñaron,
y ahora se van a involucrar,
observando cómo se adoptan estas cosas en una serie de ciudades
como Atlanta, donde vamos a hacer pruebas para ver si realmente puede
ayudar a reactivar la zona centro.
(Aplausos)
Lo importante es, ya les creas a las Naciones Unidas
o a cualquier otro gabinete estratégico,
en los próximos 20 años todo el crecimiento de la población de este planeta
será en las ciudades.
Sólo en Asia será de más de 1.000 millones de personas.
Aprendieron a empezar con los móviles.
No tuvieron que recorrer el camino de un siglo que recorrimos nosotros.
Empezaron en lo más alto de la cadena alimentaria tecnológica.
Tenemos que empezar a construir ciudades y entornos humanos
en los que una persona de 70 kilos pueda recorrer un par de kilómetros
en un entorno verde, rico y denso
sin necesitar una máquina de 2.000 kilos para hacerlo.
Los coches no se idearon para aparcar uno al lado de otro;
son máquinas maravillosas para ir de ciudad en ciudad, pero pensad en ello.
Hemos resuelto todos los problemas de largo alcance y gran velocidad.
Los griegos iban del teatro de Dionisos al Partenón en sandalias;
tú lo haces en deportivas.
Las cosas no han cambiado tanto.
Si esta cosa va sólo el triple de rápido que una persona caminando... el triple...
un paseo de media hora se convierte en 10 minutos.
Tú eliges, cuando vives en una ciudad, si ahora son 10 minutos...
porque cuando son 30 quieres una alternativa, ya sea el autobús, el tren...
Tenemos que construir una infraestructura, un tren ligero,
o vas a tener que seguir aparcando coches.
Pero si pudieras señalar la mayoría de las ciudades e imaginar
cuánto podrías recorrer, si tuvieras tiempo, en media hora, sería la ciudad.
Si pudieras hacerlo divertido y convertirlo en 8 ó 10 minutos,
no podrías encontrar el coche, desaparcar, moverlo,
volver a aparcar e ir a donde sea;
no puedes hacerlo llamando a un taxi o en metro.
Podríamos cambiar la forma en que la gente aprovecha sus recursos,
la forma en que este planeta utiliza la energía,
y hacerlo más divertido.
Y esperamos que, hasta cierto punto, la historia diga que teníamos razón.
Eso es un Segway. Esto es un motor Stirling;
eso se ha confundido con muchas cosas que estamos haciendo.
Esta pequeña bestia, ahora mismo, está produciendo unos cientos de vatios de electricidad.
Sí, se podría colocar aquí,
y sí, con un kilo de propano
podríais conducir de Nueva York a Boston si quisieras.
Quizá lo más interesante de este motorcito es que quema cualquier tipo de
combustible, porque algunos podríais ser escépticos
en cuanto a la capacidad de esto de dejar su huella
en los lugares del mundo donde simplemente no puedes enchufarlo a una toma de
120 voltios. Hemos trabajado en ello,
en realidad, como una fuente de energía alternativa,
empezando hace tiempo con Johnson & Johnson, para hacer funcionar un iBOT,
porque las mejores baterías que podías encontrar...
eran de 10 vatios-hora por kilo de plomo;
20 vatios-hora por kilo de niquel-cadmio;
40 vatios-hora por kilo de niquel e hidruro metálico;
60 vatios-hora por kilo de litio;
y 8.750 vatios-hora de energía por kilo de propano o gasolina;
que es por lo que nadie tiene coches eléctricos.
Pero en cualquier caso, si puedes quemarlo con la misma eficiencia,
porque es combustión externa como el fogón de tu cocina,
si puedes quemar cualquier combustible, resulta que está bastante bien.
Genera la electricidad suficiente como para, por ejemplo, hacer esto...
lo que por la noche es suficiente electricidad, en el resto del mundo,
como señaló el señor Holly -el doctor Holly-
para hacer funcionar ordenadores y una bombilla.
Pero lo más interesante es la termodinámica de esto. Digamos
que nunca vas a obtener más del 20% de eficiencia.
No importa mucho, dice que si obtienes 200 vatios de electricidad,
tendrás 700 u 800 vatios de calor.
Si quisieras hervir agua y recondensarla a un ritmo de 40 litros por hora,
necesitarías unos 25... un poco más de 25,3 kilovatios...
25.000 vatios de potencia contínua para hacerlo.
Eso es mucha energía, no podrías permitirte desalinizar
o limpiar agua en este país de esa forma.
Ciertamente, en el resto del mundo la opción es destruir el lugar,
convertir todo lo que se pueda quemar en calor, o beber el agua que haya disponible.
La causa número uno de muerte en este planeta en humanos es el agua insalubre.
Dependiendo de las cifras de quien te creas,
está entre 60 y 85.000 personas al día.
No necesitamos sofisticados transplantes de corazón en el mundo.
Necesitamos agua.
Y las mujeres no tendrían que pasarse cuatro horas al día yendo a buscarla
o viendo cómo mueren sus hijos.
Hemos ideado cómo poner un destilador de compresión de vapor en esto,
con un intercambiador de calor de contra-flujo para recuperar el calor residual,
usando un poco de electricidad controlar ese proceso,
y por 450 vatios, que es un poco más de la mitad de su calor residual,
producirá 40 litros por hora de agua destilada
a partir de cualquier cosa que le pongas para que lo enfríe.
Así que si ponemos esta caja aquí en unos años,
podríamos tener la solución al transporte, a la electricidad,
y a las comunicaciones, y quizá al agua potable
en un paquete sostenible que pesa... ¿30 kilos?
No sé, pero lo intentaremos.
Será mejor que me calle ya.
(Aplausos)